We are days away
from the 2016 election,
and the country
hasn't been this divided
since way back a few weeks ago
when we were all fighting about
that picture of the dog wearing
pants two different ways!
I don't know!
I don't know
what the right answer is!
-They both seem plausible!
-(laughter)
But if there's one thing
that can bring us together,
it's Starbucks.
Ah, Starbucks.
Their new cup features a mosaic
of over 100 diverse people
who would never actually hang
out in real life,
but it's a nice thought.
Meant to be a symbol of unity.
And it worked,
'cause everyone loves it.
Oh, wait. They don't,
'cause (bleep) the Internet.
(laughter)
"Now that
"beloved diversity
has blown up in our faces,
"the libs @Starbucks
have begun shilling for unity.
LOL, comma, comma, comma,
how typical."
(laughter)
What does that even mean?!
How do you shill for unity?
It's not a corporation.
It's a concept!
How does this possibly
anger you?
-Take your meds, Philip.
Take them. -(laughter)
Do you not have
a single real problem?
"I don't drink Coke
'cause the can is communist red.
"Don't even get me started
on Twizzlers.
-That candy aisle is rigged!
It's rigged!" -(laughter)
People are using the cup
as an excuse to be angry,
much like I'm using it
to be sarcastic.
So, comedians,
manufacture some outrage
about the delightful new
Starbucks cup. Tiffany.
The cup doesn't really represent
actual Starbucks customers.
Where are the people that are
masturbating in the bathroom?
-I'm just saying. -Yeah, yeah,
yeah, points, yeah, yeah.
(laughter, applause)
Well, uh, fap and a frappe.
-That should be their new, uh...
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
That should be their new motto?
Company tag line?
Brian.
My Coffee Bean Aryan Nation
travel mug
holds way more coffee.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Points. Jim.
To get outraged, just use the
regular Starbucks cup,
but put Dunkin' Donuts coffee
in there.
HARDWICK: Yeah, all right.
That's the way to do it.
-(laughter, applause)
-Points to Jim Jefferies.
Switch it up, switch it up.